he's the Commissioner of the PGA Tour is
jay monahan who is joining us here we
got some rain in the forecast here so
they sent the golfers out about an hour
earlier and wind and rain is coming in
do you had the final say so Commissioner
if they were going to the delay
postponed we had a lot of smart people
that are we have a meteorologist and a
group of rules officials to travel
weekend and week out and are used to
dealing with situations like this and we
have every confidence in them what about
the wind if it's raining no lightning no
thunder but let's say the winds get up
to 35 outside to safety and on your over
this is unique in that you're over three
golf courses but the safety of our
players and safety the amateurs and fans
will be will be that the consideration
point for the decision that's made and
be in the Commissioner of the PGA Tour
like it's the one sport where you can be
the commissioner and also be able to
play yes and you know as well adam
silver is not going to be playing
basketball he can't dunk your handicap
is at five so you could go out and be
respectable and play with phil mickelson
unlike what just happened yeah there yes
yes I wasn't gonna mention it I was not
going to well I think that listen I
think that this sport you know it it's a
generational sport when dan patrick has
a big birthday he decides that he's
going to of all the opportunities he has
in his life he's going to come out to
Pebble Beach and play golf with his
friends and whether you're ten or you're
80 this is a sport that you can play for
your entire lifetime and I think this
event more so than any other because
you're pairing the world's best players
with leaders celebrities people that are
really passionate about the game really
illustrates that in a way that's so
powerful every Commissioner is looking
at the next generation you know
baseball's toying with extra innings
where you start a runner at second base
to speed up the game everybody's talking
about you know the NFL and how do we
speed up the game the end of an NBA game
how do we speed up the game yours is
different you're not trying to speed
anything up but you're also trying to
attract that next generation so what is
the strategy for that well I think
listen I think in today's day and age
everybody's trying to do what they did
last year faster
and so you have to look at you have to
look at what faster looks like in your
sport and and faster leads to innovation
and you know we've we've announced a
format change in our tournament New
Orleans and we're constantly thinking
about what we can do within the field of
play but as importantly you got to start
with your fans and what are your fans
want to consume what do they want to see
with jordan Spieth and from jordan
Spieth and our top players so it's
really a matter how you're producing
your tournaments showcasing in
tournaments distributing your content
and those are things that are very
dynamic and we're constantly thinking of
and we go but but you look at the NFL
they're toying with things they opened
up the offense baseball you know they
brought in the fences basketball the
three-point shot you can't put your
hands on an offensive player anymore can
golf do anything where you're you're
making it more we seem to 59 s here yeah
I don't know like what do you want if I
was going to say offensively for golf
aside from the equipment of the golf
balls or is that the innovation that's
making it more interesting well I think
I think what you want is competitive
friction you want to have if you have a
hundred and fifty six players here you
want to when you get to Saturday and
Sunday you want to have what we've had
for the past couple years which is 10 to
12 even higher number of players within
two or three shots as you come down to
the end because that competitive
friction draws interest and I think
right now we have balance across our
membership you've got great players
great international players and I think
I think if so long as there's
competitive friction there's going to be
great interest in this fort but to your
to your question is there's some big
gotcha some big change that is on the
horizon that's going to you know that
it's going to change everything know the
sport has proven that over time it's the
format as it stands the 72-hole
stroke-play format always pulls out the
best players and there are small tweaks
will make but we're very comfortable
with the structure of our confidence
would you ever have a standard golf ball
that's used because I don't know if it's
the golf ball of the equipment but we're
starting to see guys just take apart you
know certain the part
fives where you're hitting a driver you
know a 9-iron it's not the way golf is
meant to be played what would make you
nervous as we move forward with the
technology is that the golf bar is at
the clubs well I think if you look at
the data the data has not changed to
significantly in terms of driving
distance and the player that's on the
bottom end of the spectrum to the
longest driver over the last 10 to 12
years as something we monitor closely
the USGA and art and RNA monitor closely
but sure if you got to a point where
technology innovation led to golf course
is becoming truly obsolete then you've
got to make a change but I think in
working with all the other golfing
organizations we're very comfortable
with where the game is and distance and
power coupled with finesse are
attributes that that fans love to see
it's very aspirational is jay monahan
the Commissioner of the PGA Tour if you
could have a tiger another tiger or
let's say five guys who were sharing
majors hmm I would listen I think what
Tiger has accomplished in his career to
have it to have a an athlete that's been
the greatest of all time conversation
that they once in a generation talent is
an absolutely spectacular thing for any
sports so it's you'd love to have that
at any given point in time at the same
time this board is demonstrate we either
have that or we have what you just said
which is a group of stars that are
emerging that are highly competitive and
you fluctuate between who's the best at
certain times and i think i think what
we'd like to have is what we have right
now which you're in a period where you
have those group of stars and you don't
really know who's going to emerge as the
next big star and I think not
understanding in some cases is better
than understanding because that draws
interest to your sport and I think the
beautiful thing is you've got you just
mentioned four or five we could go down
the list and get to 12 to 15 and you
also add people like players like a
dekhi matsuyama from Japan what he's
doing for this game over in Japan and
the interest he's creating at the same
time that we're creating interest here
with him and through these other stars
it's phenomenal I mean it we're very
lucky to have that
you grow up in the Boston area I did Red
Sox fan Red Sox fan former red sox
employee okay Patriots I'm everything
but we'll cut right to it I love every
Boston team did you like him up on the
Patriots on Super Bowl Sunday it's your
down 25 I was highly concerned where's
just where you still watching oh yeah
are you kidding okay I a lot of people
who didn't I'll tell you a great story I
told to a bunch of people my father
turned to my daughter and told her to
take a picture of the scoreboard and she
said why my daughter's 13 years old and
he said because you're about to watch
the greatest comeback so that's a memory
I'll never forget do you always get golf
applause like does anybody ever give you
regular applause if you do something
well or is it big well I think what we
just experienced over there is generally
what kind of response i get which is
that i will know yes greatest no it's no
long we see the environment at the waste
management Phoenix Open can you
replicate that could you have another
event on tour that had that feel to it
well it's interesting because we get
that question from every other sport and
from all of our tournaments and everyone
sees what it is you know and a try and
everyone would like to get to those
sides crowds that level of interest that
return for charity that level of
excitement I'm not sure it's possible
that is you're talking decades of work
in that community to get to that point
and to build something that's so
culturally significant there so but you
have the audience playing of the gallery
is playing a role yeah normally the
gallery doesn't play a role in a golf
event not to that degree i would agree
yeah it is it is it's very unique in
that respect but i want to have another
one wilmore else on tour i think i think
having one separates that event it makes
it makes it truly different I'm not so
certain I think every event has to have
its own identity that one has hit and I
think there are certain tournaments
where you've got I mean you obviously
have great following and great energy in
the crowds that's that's that but that
eventually unique yes holy all the
danettes have every
and questions for the commissioners Oh
as commissioner of the PGA's you have
the power and would you use the pop of
the power to make sure they never remake
the movie Caddyshack do you have that
kind of pull never remake it well they
did counties check to which is
embarrassment your predecessor should
have taken care of it could you use your
power to make sure they never make
Caddyshack do with the cooperation of
the PGA I would I don't have that kind
of power i'm sorry Wow for it yes wow
wow yeah but if someone that's watched
that movie over a hundred times ya see
what is your position as white belts as
an accessory on tour very good question
white belts as an accessory I have a
problem with players that can pull it
off and there is certain that can it's
like any fashion accessory to each his
own and I think that that's a personal
decision that's fair do you want to call
out any of the golfers do you think
shouldn't be wearing a white belt
Commissioner I am not prepared at all
times yes rich because I can't hit a
golf ball for the life of me I created a
spotter for everyone is there a
miniature golf course near Pebble Beach
so I can take a look at how you're just
to work my way up from windmills and
clowns noses to eventually maybe
actually hit something I think before
you go to an actual physical miniature
golf course you may want to spend some
time on line may be playing some
simulated girls and then once you get to
a place where you feel like you're
comfortable call me and we'll get you
good luck wherever you are it's a great
idea yes mclovin do you think Julian
Edelman's catch was one of the greatest
of all time it was only first down we're
having a huge space behind it's not
clean to watch well I listen I was you
go back to the David Tyree catch and
obviously I'm a Patriots fan and that to
me I still wake up at night the middle
night sometimes in a cold sweat they can
think about that play and to me those
two catches are highly comparable I
think everybody from New England's
thought about at that at that point in
time and i would say that those are the
two greatest catches of all time
Commissioner thanks for stopping by
thank you and good luck I can always
clinically got a long tenure and we
appreciate your joining us the Dan
Patrick show weekday morning on audience
you